[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
now
[Music]
all right guys
all right so
here's the bad news
King cannot make it unfortunately
I don't know what's happening with uh
his stuff apparently like because we
have like a family plan for Nintendo and
when we would go to make him to get him
part of it it wasn't working correctly
uh so I apologize for that it just
happened
so
we're gonna play we're gonna rock with
it though man we're gonna rock with it I
I definitely would love to have had that
you know I hate the fact that we
couldn't do that
but I've already started the stream he
just told me literally after I started
the stream so I couldn't
[Music]
okay gotta make a new picture real quick
there's not really many good pictures of
Pokemon Stadium
I don't know why that is
[Music]
we're just gonna keep the picture what
it is
[Music]
all right we'll keep the picture what it
is
what we're gonna do is we're gonna take
out the gym leaders first
[Music]
so we got broth he's brought
let's go with nothing but a bunch of
water pokemon let's go with glass toys
[Music]
go grass too
I don't know about bio plume let's keep
looking
[Music]
let's go Gengar just because I like Game
Boy
star me for quickness
[Music]
I'm probably about to straight up flops
but we're going with these people
foreign
[Music]
this is straight up we win in this
doesn't even matter what we send it I
sent random Pokemon we bring you this
battle live from gym leader Castle how
will our Intrepid Challenger fare
against the best
[Music]
let's just hide your pump it out
here's the first move
and head
it's building energy for the next attack
what a furious battle
[Music]
see what we'll do is we'll imagine that
that's what's going on one imagine that
that's that's King all right and if it
was King and I would actually be
fighting them I would go for another
hydro pump
what now
I'm pushing the wrong button clearly
that's gonna hurt me actually
neither one is
[Music]
that gonna work
why does it keep being strength right
look unfortunately Keith couldn't make
it man uh he he was having issues with
his
with his Subscription Service it wasn't
working the way it was supposed to
battle continues
[Music]
I think he was avoid of me though
I think he was avoiding me that's that's
my story King got his story my story
that man's was avoiding
me
that was that's my my story imma stick
by my store
we got a Weedle
we're just gonna hydro pump it out
look at that we almost had him
poison thing probably hit us twice
[Music]
doesn't even really matter that we're
poisoned at this moment
because we still gonna win
[Music]
oh
they're both down different than the
number of reserved Pokemon
[Music]
so I gotta the remaining Pokemon count
is three to one the battle has become
one side let's finish this up real quick
I love Pokemon man
[Music]
we're gonna beat
it Furious battle
hold up
[Music]
what now it's a light hit
Savage attack there is a hit
wow going down
[Music]
um
I could play them see the problem is
with the uh the Pro Controller it's a
little bit different all right so hold
up it's got some grass in here
[Music]
's the second adversary the Challenger
needs to stay calm to earn victory
[Music]
here's the first move
see man what I don't agree with is the
fact that a Dragon Knight has this has
like the worst moves that known the man
so bad I think I'm going to
switch to the Gengar
[Music]
oh
this is the goat right here
will this Pokemon swap change the flow
of battles we're gonna do Thunderbolt
because I'm feeling extra froggy today
[Music]
got paralyzed so I'm going first every
time
[Applause]
[Music]
what's this
it's not very effective
[Music]
defective
the intense battle see now you're all
shy
yeah cause now you like
yeah now you all try yes the Pokemon has
some of the worst moves in this game
unless you make the Gameboy I don't
understand why they didn't let you
connect some form of game or something
like you know it's in a really [__] and
I've just went in here straight up with
HP default set
[Music]
s
oh my because I'm trying to play this oh
is it down and out
what will the next Pokemon be
I I ain't been took out yet though you
got an Oddish
all this ain't doing the remaining
Pokemon count as Gengar That's my boy
this battle is still on the air
20 years
look don't be making fun of my games
when in doubt thunderbolted out nothing
can't not be resolved with the
Thunderbolts
it's not very effective
what a furious battle This is Gonna Keep
thunderbolting It uh Christian
[Music]
you know what they should have did
Christian they should have attached the
Game Boy
to the switch
but the opponent appears that's what
they should have done they should have
attached the Game Boy to the switch
[Music]
there's a difference
he only says that when you have lost any
and they've lost two oh it's so bad
the remaining Pokemon counted three to
one the battle has become one-sided
how's that
that one first
why take it down with one hit
and there goes the battle
secondly the second gym leader down like
it was nothing
[Music]
I'm a Pokemon Master you can get it
right
in all games Matt no Pokemon Master
no I didn't ask for that I asked for the
Pokemon Master title
got it from there
so so big there's six Pokemon up there
pick pick which ones put up down a b
[Music]
up down now which ones pick
a yeah
[Music]
three
I have no clue what Pokemon she picked
waiting right right
oh we bout to we about to mess up oh
Thunder I'm streaming
Thunder it's done
looks like the bad Pokemon choice you
guys have no idea how much I've played
this
[Music]
you guys have no idea how many times
I've played this game
[Music]
I'm streaming
bubble Bean
storming is such a good Pokemon
looks strong
[Music]
I think that would actually hurt me
I mean I guess everything in this game
is gonna hurt you there's a big
difference in HP yeah there's a big
difference because I'm about to win
but the pop another bubble bee matter
[Music]
oh is it down and out oh they're both
there's a difference in the number of
reserved Pokemon you guys have no idea
how much this
this these old sayings are getting me
man the remaining Pokemon count is three
to one the battle has become look at
this I'm about to dig this Diglett
Straight to Hell
hey an effective hit
your team one
your team demolish them babe
you wanna pick the next team
actually this next team's the gym leader
Brock
[Music]
I'm about to let her play the bra fight
I'm about to get scrooched
are we about to see we about to see
[Music]
all right right
yeah okay
[Music]
I'm sure you pick right yes you push
eight no you have to push this button
and then right
um stop questioning me okay
left
[Music]
I hope she gave you something good
I'm coming out of the Pokeball
[Music]
we're gonna bubble beam it up
not doing nothing
but bubble beam is gonna mess that vibe
how the heck did I do that again
you are you amazing baby
quick attack
didn't do nothing because of this big
giant
Pokemon I don't know how I did it
well I did pick them up
foreign
there's the first Pokemon done I want a
Pokemon Stadium three or a remaster with
all savings and all Pokemon now
how will the type difference affect that
yeah he's dumb like
[Music]
that big rock basket I think Onyx should
be way bigger than Lapras
it can't make a move
neither one is conceding in it
oh
[Music]
he's gonna keep hitting me with this
over and over again
because he's got me in this bi that's
why I call Bond
[Music]
I just gotta wait for the binder to stop
and hope that uh
you can't get me again that's why this
game's so hard because like if back in
the old days you had a Game Boy right
you could you have this like little
expanse you put in the back of your N64
and you could take your Pokemon red or
blue and put it in that expansion put it
in the N64 and use those Pokemon in this
game so you don't have any of those
options in there so I have to use these
trash
like the Pokemon that's actually in the
game and as you can see
there's a difference in the number of
reserved Pokemon
grow
he could use day
the remaining Pokemon counted three to
one the battle has become one side
[Music]
and look at that man
Brock is done
got the first gym leader up out of there
[Music]
we got the first gym leader complete now
we got a place misty
misty from the Pokemon show I haven't
played I'm about to fly
take my Pokemon
no pick hold up hold up I'm Gonna Leave
take my Pokemon and then press a please
don't pick someone
I gotta leave for work
foreign
[Music]
my phone
for telling me to go to work
[Music]
please don't send anything no fire if
they yeah it won't send fire if they
look like they can shoot like that we
amaze
okay
[Music]
oh I don't know what to pick
um
that would yeah
[Music]
no idea
I want the dragon but I know he got
fired
I know
[Music]
these are safe
uh oh wait how do I unselect it
[Music]
now you said what color
if they're yellow
oh
let's go
[Music]
how many do I have to pick
oh my God
thank you
I will pick randoms
[Music]
oh yes
wait hold on
babe I'm [__] up
[Music]
because you gotta go and we can't sit
here all day yeah
[Music]
that one
down
that one no no no no no no no
no
you're just picking stuff you see on the
show
they had Thunder
[Music]
okay I picked three
I'll land that one take that one yeah
[Music]
okay oops I'm kidding the camera huh
all right we'll pick which ones
[Music]
here's the first opponent of this gym
series a decisive Victory is expected
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
but at least she got me Pikachu man
we won
I beat squirrel
what will the next Pokemon be
cruising through life winning
how will the type difference affect that
doing another Thunderbolt
[Music]
s
watch out
oh I finally lost a Pokemon
which Pokemon is coming out
okay send me a uh
send me a link
Sabine tag me tag me on Twitter show me
this Banjo-Kazooie League because I've
been seized seeing some league and I am
skeptical
[Music]
think large is ridiculously fast wow
like ridiculously fast
there's only one Pokemon left in reserve
[Music]
oh
the remaining Pokemon stock is two to
one two to one
how's that
[Music]
taken down with one hit first one down
oh look it's awesome send it to me too
Tommy
I don't know man I don't know see I want
a Pokemon Stadium remakely that's what I
want
Tom tell me what Pokemon to pick man
even if you don't know Pokemon just tell
me what tell me what letters left right
up down a b tell me Tom
I'm gonna go in there now with my
Pokemon but with your Pokemon tell me
what what what what's Pokemon I take in
there
up down left right A B
[Music]
waiting for Tom's Pokemon unless he just
came in here said the laugh out laugh
and just popped out out of here
[Music]
the PV calling up
I don't know
um
[Music]
Tom's taking too long Christian tell me
what Pokemon is sitting there
Kadabra I don't have cadaver on me I
just have the Pokemon at the top
[Music]
no cadavers are that my Pokemon are at
the top not the bottom
I'm the trainer not the the junior one I
I'm at the top the Pikachu magnaton
Clefairy
Gengar Meowth and Chansey
we'll go home boys Christian I need one
more why don't you say the next one man
I'm gonna I'm gonna go with it
right okay
Magneton okay let's go with magnitude
[Music]
he says he can't post it public because
of copyright wrong effort to win so are
we talking about like the leak
then send me a Who
why not
[Music]
whoa okay
I'm about to win with this club Fairy
[Music]
what now you need to DM someone tell
them to DM me or Tom Henderson DM one of
us
right Thunderbolt that one hurts
oh is it down and out
what will the next Pokemon be
[Music]
oh
will the type difference affect that
um I thought the last Pokemon was very
lacking on the bureau
man accuracy went down I'm using
blizzard that ain't good
no
Sabine
um
go on Twitter and tag me on Twitter and
I will follow you and you can send me
whatever it is that
[Music]
here is my info
oh
[Music]
Pokemon
I did see those messages I was sent them
I didn't I don't know about by that dude
but I was sent them and
um I said I did take them to people I
know
the command and they told me they were
fake but when it comes to things like
that you never know really know what's
faking it's not fake
um probably wouldn't make a video about
it unless it gets a lot more traction
but as of right now
I'm not putting a lot of thought into
that
[Music]
what a furious battle
if I had Swift I could hit him up there
what's that
yeah my accuracy is so much smaller now
so it's it's rough
[Music]
took the whole team down
what will the next Pokemon be
let's go with Magneton
[Music]
whoa I don't know uh if the person
the remaining Pokemon stock is two to
one
come back and start making
I'm not gonna go into what happened to
my DMs but I would I was told it wasn't
true but like I said sometimes that's
not the case sometimes people just get
information they're not supposed to
happen way early but I was told it
wasn't the case
[Music]
[Applause]
All I Do Is Win
he took out what a Pokemon though took
out a Pokemon Gotta Give him crops for
that
foreign
[Music]
oh the attachment
here's the first move
uh not really I'm not really
I got a quest too I'm just not a big VR
fan in general to be honest with you
oh got him Thunder's one of the best
lightning moves you can use
it's got a it's got a less accuracy than
other lightning modes it's one of them
oh it's Holly world
[Music]
we're gonna hit him with a lightning
move too
[Music]
what now oh that's a [__]
that's a bad Pokemon choice
[Music]
Thunders that move man
there's a difference Pokemon
[Music]
this thing won't die from one hit
Pokemon
so let's Thunder Wave it first
[Music]
it's paralyzed
what's that
four five got all five
[Music]
and a critical neither one is
at the Thunder him
hopefully we hit him
[Music]
of course we got our way
he died from one hit
that's all
I told you guys
see King didn't want none of this smoke
King didn't want none of this
he was gonna lose and he knew it
he knew it
oh big boss for me you're good man no I
generally don't understand why he would
delete that comment I don't got no issue
with him
um but I'm not gonna like
I learned a while ago that if
I can't let what people do affect me on
that kind of level because people were
just gonna not like me sometimes you
know um there's people that's unfollowed
me on Twitter that I have had nothing
but good uh conversations with and you
know it is what it is
I don't know why they unfollowed me
uh but I'm not gonna like keep asking
them I'm not gonna ask them at all I
didn't ask them
it sucks because you know sometimes you
look up to these people when you're
covering content and then they just
start randomly unfollowing you for no
reason
[Music]
what now and then there's some people
that feel like
they deserve more than you just because
they have a bigger following or
something
I don't know man
people are just ridiculous they're
ridiculous
[Music]
it has to make up for a month
yeah it's got to make up for lost ground
it's not going to though I don't know it
could probably beat me yeah it'd be that
cool he's faster
I don't even know the other Pokemon that
was picked
[Music]
we're going with Gengar because I'm
pretty sure Gengar is faster than him
[Music]
oh it's Dango
the Pokemon are entirely different types
and you know when it comes down to stuff
like that Christian like I just keep
doing what I'm doing keep grinding I I'm
back to making content regularly on my
YouTube channel you know I I at first it
bother me it really did because get
people on IOP that I really respect
and you know I I respect them and then
you know they they just they ain't
really they really mess with me like
that so it is what it is not a lot I
particularly can do about it
but I I keep it moving man I keep it
moving
down there's only but you guys can
follow me on YouTube there uh King
yo I don't know I think the remaining
she said that he wasn't getting the
family email
what now
I ain't saying King Lion but I'm saying
it's awfully convenient
[Music]
yeah I've always been true to myself and
you know people can say what they want
uh you know maybe
I've been
a little bit too outspoken at some times
but it is what it is I can't go back and
change that sometimes they I I
definitely said too much than I was
supposed to
and you know
got people upset you know I I had some
people unfollow me at IGN because I was
talking about uh you know
The credibility of certain of some
journalists because it's not to be real
through there's not a lot of journalists
that I trust their opinion it's just it
is what it is
you know I got no issue with them it's
just I've seen things go down I've heard
things going down and it's not even on
their end it's the Publishers in I've
seen developers and Publishers literally
hold their game Hostage to get the type
of review that they want to get so you
know does it happen all the time I don't
know
but I don't like when people act like it
doesn't happen that that that's where I
I really draw the line and sure you know
maybe I could have worded things better
but you know I'm an influencer man
I ain't nothing else nothing more I'm an
influencer I make content if you guys
rock with me you rock with me you know
you guys always show up with the super
chats and everything and I appreciate
that because uh you know right now
things rough man
so um
I could go in there with a Gengar
because I don't think it's going to be a
huge issue there's not like a lot of
rock Pokemon in this game
in the first one
[Music]
oh
see and I'm not saying it and what's
funny is is like
the part that blows my mind about it Tom
is like I'm not even talking about
anyone specifically I was really just
talking about the fact that I don't like
the way some publishers
try to oh you know you don't say what we
want you to say we're going to Blacklist
you're not necessarily Blacklist but
we're not going to give you a review
code the next time and instead of taking
the criticism of making a better game
they try they they try to Gaslight you
know that might be the horrible word to
use for it but they tried to to paint
their own narrative and it's that was
just me saying the stuff and you know
people really got upset
I had people from IGN legitly unfollow
me and to this day I don't know why they
unfollowed me
and I considered some of them you know
not necessarily friends but people I was
cordial with I invited them to events
that IOP would do but it is what it is
you know I've done everything I can
and
I ain't doing it anymore
influential same thing I think it's a
lot harder to to manipulate an
influencer than it is like a website
because especially some of the
influencers that actually can be
self-sufficient
uh they don't need the money
um look at what people like Angry Angry
Joe
you know
big big influence now obviously that
higher tier of mid influencers to higher
influencers they're a little bit harder
smaller influences you could you can get
away with doing them dirty to a degree
this this dude's about to mess me up
[Music]
here's the first move
I thought people just do that
I didn't know people still aren't like
making that clear because I always do I
got a code you know we shout out uh when
Microsoft uh not Microsoft but when we
were able to go see redfall we shout
that out like I thought people make that
clear but the problem is is like a lot
of people
they want to
have their own narrative and to me it's
just like dude like I call it toxic
positivity Tom where they want to make
everything spend in a in a slightly
positive way sometimes [__] just smells
like [__]
and they want to make it smell it's like
they want to spray for Brazil
oh no you know that this
there's a difference between
[Music]
constructive criticism and just trying
to protect certain business
relationships that you have and I think
that that goes down to a degree and I'm
not saying that they that's wrong
because I understand you know I've never
went at it with people I feel like you
know it makes me not really want to to
trust your opinion on stuff but I
understand some people you know
especially people that like are
that's what I'm looking for
they have more of an image to protect
and
they're a lot they have to go out
because they don't have like a huge
audience like a YouTube channel with
hundreds of thousands of Subs but they
have an image and uh you know they
they're a personality figure
since they don't have that Financial
background from having a YouTube channel
they have to really choose how they
interact on Twitter and stuff because
they don't want to upset anyone and you
know you could do that that's fine I
don't think anyone's what's the matter
question that it's like but when people
talk about those practices I shouldn't
have to go on there and censor myself to
a degree to not upset the developer or
the publisher it is what it is if you
made a bad game you should get
recommended for that but I do feel like
sometimes these developers and
Publishers they want to hold your game
their game is Ransom
to a good review
how's that
effective I I've completely
misjudged this first person they got
psychic Pokemon
there's only one
[Music]
I might be able to
two on one
[Music]
against two now
the 10th battle continue oh five dollar
super draft for the angry therapist
showing some love I appreciate it man
what do I do
you know the uh the super chats they
aren't necessary but they're definitely
they they they they they help
it's golden versus who
oh
there's just one Pokemon aside now the
battle is coming right now
let's dig
[Music]
I don't know if I'm gonna win this
but we're gonna hit him with everything
we got
but yeah that's pretty much all when it
comes to that Tom I still respect people
even if I know they don't like me it's
like it is what it is you don't like me
but you know
uh and I wouldn't even say I keep it
more real than other people I would say
that
I
if there's one if there's one thing that
you can't question when I do stuff it's
I play these games
you know
I think that's the one thing you no one
can question because I play these days I
review 88 of the games that come to IOP
yeah thankfully Cog and King and them
don't mind if I review them because I
care more about that stuff than they do
you know some people are in this
industry for like access for money I
would say I'm not in this for money I
would definitely love to do this
full-time wow but that's a different
conversation but I'm in this for Access
like I love playing games I love talking
about games I love criticizing games
that's what I'm doing this for you know
some people want to be starved
and I won that even though I barely came
through that I still won that fight
all right
yes but the thing is times like people
they they hold grudges on me for like no
reason
the second adversary the Challenger
needs to stay calm to earn victory
seeing what's funny is like
you'll see me on Twitter even though
that people have said like crazy stuff
to me I still wish the best luck like I
remember
um Paris Lilly was very upset with me
because and what I wouldn't say he was
very upset but I remember that whole
Wing was upset over my comments on the
VR and you know I still wish that dude
does because you know as much as me and
Paris don't agree on a lot of things I
respect Paris and I feel like he does
deserve a place in the industry you know
I look at passion over everything and
you could say and you can question some
of paris's choices but you can't quite
question that he he loves this one so
you know it is
[Music]
I feel that I feel that
and it's like I said you know I'm trying
to take away from anyone's opportunities
but at the same time I'm trying to get
something for myself too
the intense battle continues
you know I've never been invited to
stuff like x-cast or uh Podcast Unlocked
you know I I don't know why I couldn't I
couldn't even give you a reason why I've
never been invited to those bigger
podcasts uh it used to bother me a lot
but at the end of the day I don't care
anymore
I'm gonna chill with the people close to
me and me and them are going to build a
we're going to build a dam ourselves we
ain't trying to climb anyone else's then
we ain't trying to get people to lower
stuff for us anymore we're going to
build our own stuff and climb our own
Towers
[Music]
it didn't do much damage
people get really upset when um
with me over kid smooth
because uh their local kids moves
hurting your brand you know kids move
might say some dumb stuff and I will say
that I've probably
lost some friends over Pittsburgh but
there's not a more real person that has
decides like Cog you know King and Saul
besides my like a my immediate people in
my podcast and my family that's
been more than a friendly kids moved the
remaining Pokemon count is
[Music]
I see you Tom see ya I'm a I'm a I'ma
beat these man I'm gonna beat these
right now I'm on a
I'm on search
I could have swore that would have been
a super effective
he's gonna use self-destruct before I
could even do anything
take down
is that gonna kill me right now
we're good
[Music]
it's okay see but I wouldn't even like I
understand like where people
I think people get the words like
respectful and uh professional mixed up
like I've always said you can be
professional and you can be respectful
to when it comes to reviewing stuff but
I feel like
[Music]
sometimes somewhere along the line like
the lines have been merged together
where now any criticism to some people
can be disrespectful and I feel like we
need to separate and we need to draw a
line in the sand that says this is
disrespectful this is criticism I'm not
going around calling people's IPS or
anything like trash
I'm just criticizing some of the stuff
that they do in the game and I feel like
somewhere down the line like
people are too scared to be
critical on certain Avenues because I've
noticed that when you these days when
people give criticism to games or any
kind of movement that any of these you
know three companies do they'll say the
criticism and then they'll say something
afterwards to try to to damage control
that statement
and um you know I get it it's like I
said
I guess
thankfully I'm not
huge into like the uh why does he have
nothing but fire Pokemon
not into anything in terms of like
having me because where I'm an
influencer and I don't like make a whole
lot of money and I can't say that I
wouldn't change I want to say that the
kind of person I am
it doesn't matter how much money I would
make I would always be true to myself
but it's easy to say that from someone
that doesn't have money and from someone
that wants that back someone that wants
those opportunities because I don't know
how I would act if I had them I think I
would still keep true but I don't know
and I can't I can't give you
circumstances on a mindset I would be if
I had it because I don't know
watch out
there it's a hit
I love how you drop kids
neither one is conceding an age
the commands are issued
I hope I can at least kill this thing
before he kills me
goodness
oh and of course
I don't think he's
we'll try this I doubt this is gonna
work
we'll try this though
yeah I'm always down have conversations
Tom always down our conversation
you have a good night what will the next
I'm gonna go Gengar because Gengar is
like my favorite gen one Pokemon
it has to make up for lost ground
I wish this wasn't uh
man they need to make another Pokemon
is coming out
we got this
[Music]
is this his third or second Pokemon are
type
Gengar is bad fast like mad facts
two hitter
[Music]
I think that fire has been stalks me
from
from moving I don't know I can't
remember
[Music]
let's see if he'll let me hit
yeah it's one of those stupid moves
luckily it's not that strong hopefully
it'll only go for maybe two or three
turns I hope I don't get burned neither
one also doing this that would that
would be unfortunate
[Music]
the attack continues going on
I wonder who
who did the announcing for this game the
intense battle continues
foreign
[Music]
I've been following your content for
some time now I appreciate the knowledge
you bring to the gaming Minister however
I've noticed a Trinity's Behavior
towards fans 2D jump and runs nah it's
all jokes I I don't have no issue with
people in the 2D era it's all jokes you
know I I tend to to find something that
I can pounce at and just make jokes
about it you know
um I have no issue with people that see
is the thing like when people talk about
like
errors of gaming I can't make comments
too much gaming I wasn't around the
remaining Pokemon
the 10th battle continues
what's this
[Music]
moment
yeah my mom bought me this gun it might
have been my dad I can't remember
Thunderbolt
they It Came Out Swinging but they lost
[Music]
we won that game
we got Sarge next
[Music]
[Applause]
let's see what Sarge has for us
laughs
all right what's he going to use
I feel like
the majority of these Pokemon
[Music]
let's try this
Lieutenant surge the leader
millions of Pokemon with caution
[Music]
all right let's see here
we need ground moves to earthquake
playing Pokemon Stadium taught me one
thing uh nothing brings friends quite
together like arguing over who gets to
use YouTube in battle I didn't know that
freak oh how does Mewtwo have served
[Music]
wow
if she takes out Gengar it's a rap
and I only got Thunderbolt
[Music]
I wonder how much just regular
Thunderbolt would do
so about maybe 10 oh he's making his
face oh
this isn't good
let's do hypnosis
[Music]
please hit him please hit him please hit
him
[Music]
oh now he's gonna go faster
I gotta put him to sleep
is that the only move this thing knows
[Music]
there we go there we go okay okay
falling asleep is going to make this a
one I gotta do this dream eater
please don't wake up please don't wake
up please don't thank you
[Music]
if he doesn't wake up again we can still
come back from this let's hit the
Thunderbolt actually
all right it's still fine as long as it
can do six damage
we're good we're good
oh is it down and out took out a Pokemon
what will the next Pokemon game on B
let's just hope this next thing don't
have water
oh this thing got surfed too I can
almost guarantee you this thing got
surfed through the Pokemon
let's hypnose again
we're not risking this
we're putting this thing straight to
sleep
and it failed
[Music]
miss miss miss miss miss me critical too
fireworks aren't flying in this battle
we're going for it again
come on put them to sleep please water
please work
oh it's rap for a Gengar
oh it's a rat because this guy surf two
and I'm pretty sure raichu's faster than
whatever my Pokemon is
there's only one Pokemon left in reserve
okay go along
if I could get the hit on I'm pretty
sure I can win but I highly doubt it I
highly doubt it
I'd be very surprised
[Music]
I got swept by a right a Pikachu and
Raichu that new surf
[Music]
they did that on purpose
we're gonna go with the same team
[Music]
[Applause]
here comes the first opponent
Henry should be within race
no I'm not risking it
yeah see Bumblebee might kill me
[Music]
man I don't know
this is a wild one from the word go
[Music]
all right we're gonna go pawn shop
fewer candies in there I'm a champ uh I
like it what's up Spiderman
[Music]
Pro fighting type
I used to what now
what's that look at that
it's gonna be a long fight
let's dig
you know what's funny you know these
these Charizards that that are worth
like all this money now that like Logan
Paul and them are getting I used to have
like eight of them back in the day
neither one is conceding an inch
here's a Pokemon
[Music]
will this Pokemon swap change the flow
of battle
I'll just thinking
yeah super effective should have been a
reason why they switched
[Applause]
there's a difference in the number of
reserved Pokemon
[Music]
oh it's on it
there's only one Pokemon against three
the battle has become one-sided we're
probably losing this guys
it has like a 50 chance of actually
hitting to you
[Music]
we're running
we ain't winning
we're going in there with an actual team
man
[Music]
we select all Pokemon
okay so I do think we need a couple
earth type
[Music]
foreign
what's funny is like all the Pokemon now
it's kind of crazy that this is the only
option that you realistically have
[Music]
um
let's go with him
obviously our boy Gengar
[Music]
the mission Thunder
reflect
[Music]
answer
is actually a really good a lot of PVP
Pokemon
[Music]
fighting time
[Applause]
[Music]
laughs
all right let's do it let's do this the
first opponent an easy Victory should be
within reefs
we have to make it a little bit harder
for them just to one shot us
[Music]
yes he ain't doing that to me again
you get me once man just once
I think I dug a hole too
no earthquake what now
we're just going to earthquake him again
because we want that hit the moment he
comes up unless it kills Lickitung
lickitung's are normal so I don't see it
killing me
[Music]
yeah I kind of figured it would be would
be good
the intense battle continues
[Music]
is he really gonna take me out no
horrible
it's looking spooky there for a second
in this battle I think he's faster than
me though
it's okay we're good
what will the next Pokemon be let's get
Gengar because that Golem's just gonna
get mocked
oh
it has to make up for lost
how will the type difference affect
faster
gengar's faster than most things in this
game
[Music]
which Pokemon is coming out
oh it's flawful
the Pokemon are entirely different type
[Music]
I don't think the Thunderbolt could do
something
okay why is Laura playing Pokemon
not cause it's on uh it's on the switch
uh the switch program now
you heard it's on the switch program now
the remaining Pokemon
two to one
[Music]
effective
God hit the one hit wonder we win
so that's how you win things
boom boom boom boom
they took up my lucky thumb though I'm
kind of upset by that
[Music]
we could win this stuff
I just hope that Pikachu doesn't know um
[Music]
I hope that Pikachu doesn't know sir
here's the second adversary the
Challenger needs to stay calm to earn
victory
it's a good hypnosis him
[Music]
I don't feel comfortable until
all right so that is
we're gonna have to hypnosis him again
it's like the only
fight we have right now watch out
[Music]
fast asleep good falling asleep is going
to make this a one-sided fight we gotta
do a little bit of damage
I wish we had a better Gengar
we can hit him twice that would be
wonderful
yeah okay we good
[Music]
oh is it down and out
what will the next Pokemon be
oh
how will the type difference affect that
laughs
[Music]
yeah I guess you're doing hypnosis again
let's hope we get him first time
yep we got him the first time he's
probably gonna wake right up there
no we're good
how will this news affect the back
dream meter is the goat
[Music]
it's crazy to damage it does
stop the intense battle continues
[Music]
now
this is a Pokemon not trying to get him
back asleep take too long
[Music]
my defense
this dude already has really good
defense from the start so I don't have
to worry about too much on that
[Music]
yeah it's working
Underground
what a furious battle
what's this
the move failed to click
dick [__]
super effective
uh no I'm not currently playing
ghostwire
um there's a difference I don't even
know if I'm allowed to tell you what
game I'm playing right now
yo this movement is to lick his opponent
five dollars
appreciate the uh fight all Super Chat
man
yeah and this Pikachu probably gonna
know surf watch
no body slam okay we good
not very effective
[Music]
feeding an itch
what now
oh the attachment
how's that that one hurts
[Music]
and there goes the battle
uh no I'm not playing redfall
I'm not playing red
foreign
[Music]
I'm almost done with the game that I'm
playing
that's waiting right after this
you guys could probably guess what I'm
playing to be honest with you
[Music]
no I could tell you're not right now I'm
not playing redfall apparently I don't
have the code for it yet I'm pretty sure
I'm gonna get one though
[Music]
I you know regardless with the 30 frame
thing I don't want to say too many of my
bars because I'm gonna wait for IOP I'm
optimistic I'm hoping that you know even
though see I guess the reason that it
doesn't really bother me is because the
30 frames is going to really reply apply
to me I'll just play it on PC
what no I'm not playing Minecraft either
it's a third party game I'll tell you
that
it's not an exclusive to any platform
earthquakes
super effective
oh is it down and out
[Music]
what will the next Pokemon be
oh committer and mail
it has to make up for lost ground I'm
pretty sure if you really look at the
game that's coming out
you should know what it is
wow that's an effective hit
at least I get hit him one time before
he takes me out watch it Miss because
the earthquake misses a lot
it's like a bad Pokemon they didn't kill
him though but it got him neither one is
[Music]
a Pokemon
oh it's Danger
[Music]
what's next
oh the attack
will this Pokemon swap change the flow
of battle
I'll kill you
there's a difference in the number of
reserved Pokemon
I should be fine here I don't think uh
this thing's gonna come back and win one
little
the remaining Pokemon count is three to
one
you should be fine we should be fine
[Music]
gotta hit him one more time but we good
I don't even think Thunder's gonna be
enough to kill him
yeah
what a furious battle
gengar's weak to psychic and ghost he'd
have to get hit by uh by mirror or get
hit by um like a Nightshade or psychic
one of those moves
oh Dead Island maybe I won't confirm or
deny that
[Music]
foreign
this should do some damage Pikachu's
probably gonna go first
please don't kill him in one hit
[Music]
all right we're good uh no I haven't
played the half-life games before
[Music]
critical and super that might be a wrap
yep that's a wrap
[Music]
you
how will the type difference affect that
I agree with you Cuban that's why you
need to go right now download it and
play it even if you just claim the
starting screen over and over again show
the engagement
show how many people might pick up
Pokemon Stadium we want another one
Pokemon
that right you took that hit like like a
chance
down and out
I think Gengar is one of my people
slow bro
I don't know Slowbro is going to be able
to hit get hit by this thing
the Pokemon are entirely different type
let's dig
raichu's definitely faster
[Music]
Pokemon looks wrong
come on dick please dick please dig oh
my God it's still my screw me but if he
can get this move through we got it we
got it if you can get it
okay I don't think surf can hit him
[Music]
please
there's only one but I don't know what
PC you got but if it's even close to
that place to hooked up and play that
um I have
the remaining Pokemon I have a 30 60 TI
let me
look at my specs
I have a 3060 TI with a ryzen 7 5800 X
they're staring each other down
that's and I have 16 gigabytes of uh
of RAM
retrainer hasn't issued an order
he's paralyzed he's a rat sonic boom
used to play Pokemon Stadium and puzzle
see the control is weird I would love to
play the Pokemon stage uh the the mini
games but the Pokemon uh the the control
is weird
there's just one Pokemon inside now
please hit him please hit him please hit
him please hit him please hit oh Sonic
Boom don't kill him don't kill him don't
kill him
oh yeah you built like a tank
he's taking all that damage
[Music]
I think we got it boys I think we got it
I don't think that's it
[Music]
that's it
we beat the third gym leader
I love that sound
[Music]
I never was
to catch them is
[Music]
my car all right so this this chick
likes using grass so let's let's get the
old Charizard out man
[Music]
rather die
gotta get Gengar
[Music]
I don't want him
special
fire blast let's see what Moltres can do
special is 153 yeah let's get motris
[Music]
not the greatest
roll right there
arcane
[Music]
yeah we'll go for it
foreign
[Music]
butter-free Butterfree is a good Pokemon
let's pick something random
uh yeah that's good if you're looking to
play one of the most Innovative games
ever play there just saying I might try
it
[Music]
here's the first opponent of this gym
series a decisive Victory is expected
[Music]
thank you
I will totally have fire blasts on this
blast on the Gengar if I could
here's the first move
and the weak spot
but I can't so I'm not going to
head
what a furious battle
[Music]
we won yeah
and they're remaking everything these
days what will the next
Punk be
so far we're good though guys we're good
I don't really see
what this dude causing us too much issue
Gengar don't really have a whole lot of
weaknesses in this game
[Music]
watch out
oh the attack death
what
Theodore show me
what you're talking about tag me in it
because people's coming in here talking
about my banjo
and I need to see it
cause I'll make a video about it
that'll be my video
for tomorrow
[Music]
I got someone else got to be covering it
man the commands are issued you hear me
someone's gotta cover it it can't be me
[Music]
whoa this one missed two
fireworks are flying in this battle
maybe I can't hit him with these moves
what's up
oh yeah I probably should try to end
with something else
[Music]
put him to sleep
see I don't see no one yet
[Music]
I don't see no one talking about it holy
what's next
does nothing work on this dude
[Music]
the heated battle rages off
jettison Fortune
um tag
I gotta wait for something to come on
Twitter
I look mad suspect if I cover something
unfortunately
[Music]
each other
here's the Pokemon thing
let's look up banjo
Banjo-Kazooie
on Twitter
[Music]
all right so no one's talking about that
what now
oh it's another mix
the intense battle comes away
[Music]
I'm looking at it now
what's that
nail the weak [__]
what a furious battle
yeah I don't see no one talking about it
[Music]
it's probably safe they need to bring
this back I need like a news article to
report it I've talked to him
[Music]
offender I've talked to him
it's been Fair it's a hit
I sent it to people
they told me it was fake
so if like some I don't want to make a
video on it unless like other people are
talking about it
[Music]
underground again
it's crashing about
what will it do miss the target
neither one is succeeding an age
yeah finally we took him out it's
finally taken down
there's a difference in the number of
reserved Pokemon
oh it's Wigglytuff
remaining Pokemon
the battle has become one we're gonna
dig
probably not the greatest thing for me
to do because he's still pretty strong
even with the digging
[Music]
we good
man it's not doing much damage at all
see Charizard is weak to some stuff
we've to to thunder any kind of
lightning move with the water
[Music]
it's an AI that responds set up by the
leaker
oh
I I feel you on that ah but
I have to I have to see other people
cover it and then I will make a YouTube
you guys know how I am don't don't get
it twisted I want it to be true with
everything in me
[Music]
I'll hit a brand
like I told you guys I want it to be
true I love Pokemon I want it to be true
[Music]
I don't even was that the first or
second at first
kill me
Erica's gonna be pain
you got some Waters in there
got some rocks
[Music]
the Gengar is probably the best person
going there with
we'll need a strong effort to win
Gengar I got nothing for this thing
but Gengar can put him to sleep
[Music]
because that's what we do
and most the time it fails
[Music]
see at least they missed two
but we're going for this sleep again
God put this dude up man you gotta go to
bed
and it failed again
[Music]
he's gonna hit me this time
whoa
[Music]
he missed
so we're gonna keep it up we're gonna
try to put him to sleep again
and it didn't work again
he's gonna hit me with this thunder
I told you
it was just a matter of time before
we're going for another one
there we go we won
[Music]
now we get some of that some of that
back
[Music]
oh
Grace better
[Music]
will this Pokemon swap change I should
use Thunderbolt
[Music]
s
continues
now
[Music]
fireworks are flying in this battle
here we go
probably gonna finish this gym
or this round I don't know if I'll beat
Erica and probably call it a stream
depending on how I'm feeling man
right now I'm feeling pretty good
let's dream eat this thing I should go
first
why is he keep Pokemon change
oh it's the Jonah he's doing that on
purpose
[Music]
uh this Thunderbolt in before he
switches I don't know who's faster
Pidgeot could you uh Pokemon Pidgeotto
or Gengar I would say yeah Gengar is
definitely fast
[Music]
Pokemon oh so close
I wonder what knives
it just depends
childish like I think that
they're putting these older ones out on
the N64 to see some type of Engagement
and if it works out pretty good then
they might remake them I don't know
will this Pokemon swap change the flow
of battle I should have used tape tackle
[Music]
okay so we got that
oh
we good
there's a difference in the number of
reserved Pokemon
[Music]
the remaining Pokemon found in three to
one the battle has become one let's go
back to Gengar
I feel like we have a good chance of
Gengar if he doesn't wake up we can
dream meet him next turn
at least we'll know
woke up oh
I want to put him back to sleep
hopefully we can
[Music]
look probably about to beat me with
these Thunders
neither one is trying it
it's everything or nothing
[Music]
[Applause]
man this Gengar taking a Beat
[Music]
continue
doing thunderborn things useless
it's probably not gonna go to sleep
is it gonna wake up again immediately
okay we could we can hit him one time
how much health they'll give me back
what will it do
the bear pick oh a decent amount
[Music]
fireworks we'll put it back to sleep
[Applause]
I'm gonna try it again though
because if I hit him with thunder it's
not gonna do nothing
my best course of action right now is to
put him to sleep
again
[Music]
it's fast asleep
how will this news affect the fact
[Music]
now oh he's asleep I could have ended it
though
what's this I wasn't paying attention
watch him wake up too
[Music]
yeah
zober makes no sense
come on man
neither one is conceiving
come back
let's sleep again
[Music]
it's a wrap
falling asleep is going to make this a
one-sided fight
we good we good people
everything makes sense again
it's kind of ridiculous how many times
[Music]
all right we got cooler than Eric
what remember when um
got pretty much a same person as the
first one
[Music]
here's the third trainer battle with
only the gym leader left after this what
kind of battle can we expect to see
I feel like this thing can definitely
hit me with a psychic movie
[Music]
what a furious battle
Pokemon
it's not a good matchup
[Music]
what now oh the attachment
will this Pokemon swap change order of
Moltres is faster than this thing better
be
Fire Flash
super effective
oh is it down and out
what will the next Pokemon be
weighing this for the W guys weighing
this for the doubles
oh a Chancey Chancey never did that
let's just go straight for another fire
blast probably won't kill him but he'll
do a good amount of damage
nothing
[Music]
oh no it fell asleep
falling asleep is going to make this a
one-sided fight
let's go for a Gengar
[Music]
double edge
what that missed that's a normal attack
how will the swap Pokemon fight
what's this
man this thing takes a beating
[Music]
special attack
neither one is conceding we're gonna go
the hypnosis way guys
[Music]
when how much hypnosis would they do
what will it do
that
decent amount
be awesome if you didn't wake up there
we go well I'm awake get a little bit
more damage curious I did hypnosis damn
it
[Music]
he's gonna wake up
yeah finally woke up
the intense battle continues
we're going for confused right
[Music]
and Confused
what's that
[Applause]
the move fail
fireworks are flying in this battle
we're just gonna go for Thunderbolts
and hopefully with that with this
confusion
[Music]
whoa it attacked itself
the heated battle rages up that should
be it
who should we go guys we should be good
that was a pretty rough fight there's a
difference in the number of reserved
Pokemon
[Music]
Nidorino
we should be pretty easy on this thing
three to one the battle has become one
site
is a two-hitter quitter
do a breath of the Wild
[Music]
I don't have the game
currently I don't have the game what now
neither one is conceding and H
[Music]
a how's that all right that should be
all right
[Music]
battle
all right we're good
foreign
[Music]
Pokemon artist
smart strategy is the key to Victory
we're gonna go fire blast it up
I hope for the best firebot's got like a
seven percent chance of hitting whoa
looks like a bad Pokemon it's really
strong though as you can see
there's a wild one from the word ghost
[Music]
with Angela that's a poison so I don't
think that I don't think we're one shot
in that thing but we can hit him twice
we can hit him twice
[Music]
how's that
no this Pokemon looked wrong
come on take it down you're doing good
there's a difference in the number of
reserved Pokemon
[Music]
the remaining Pokemon count is three to
one that should be it battle has become
one I don't unless the uh unless the
fire blast misses
you know and it's a critical
it's a wrap
a one-hit wonder
Erica was easy
I didn't even get hit Kind of Perfect
[Music]
well that's four I saw him on the fifth
one now
is the poison dude
[Music]
foreign
oh I got a harden when the things drop
[Music]
oh I got hit
thank you
[Music]
come on WOW
thank you
drowsy I can't remember this one either
[Music]
[Applause]
oh you got hit in the middle
[Music]
oh my God
I'm losing guys
[Music]
at least it was a draw
let me pick let me pick
Le fairy one
[Music]
thank you
you're gonna have BCG on this Sunday I
don't know yet
I think he's busy
I'll hit him up though
all the magikarponed
[Music]
I forgot how decent the AI is
obviously they're not like the greatest
but
the better than most they are
these games
bringing a lot back man
[Music]
I'm losing this
I need that
[Music]
thank you
yeah I don't know how to do those
oh then I see Cog is handling all that
stuff so he might be popping through
someone's gonna eventually pick that
little fairy game yeah Clefairy says
[Music]
all right all right here we go guys
I love these gangs man
I definitely butchered that I at least
got two wrong
[Music]
yeah I got one
foreign
[Music]
yeah that's probably it
yeah I
think that's the one that picked this
game too
yeah words
I'm still ahead by one though
[Music]
oh
yeah
[Music]
foreign
can't focus on something that I can't
get oh no that's oh my God
all right got it let's go for this right
one here
[Music]
this one
and this one
there's no way I didn't get that
[Applause]
wow I was confident I won that
[Music]
a b
it's hard to do that without the uh the
N64 controller
[Music]
rematch there's no way I can go out like
that
now we're doing five
[Music]
the good thing is I should win this one
hopefully
we're good there
yeah I'm getting cooked
what sucks is when you get ahead in this
game you don't get to pick the game so
[Music]
all right it's those orange ones I gotta
get those orange ones if I can
tell you
oh
[Music]
my God
yeah I need that that's mine
that
that let me get that
let me get that
[Music]
looking for those orange ones if I can
get what I'm getting there
[Music]
I got an orange one
man that red is cute
[Music]
what are they gonna put
all right so I almost won this last time
[Music]
I just got to be more reserved
I'd rather use the hardened ability and
then get hit
[Music]
thank you
oh my God
[Music]
that's so frustrating
the Magic Carpet moved I think I could
win this one
[Music]
there's a couple I can win for sure
this one's about timing so I'm pretty
good at this
man great almost got me though
green was right there on me
watch Green lose like multiple times
oh Clefairy man
[Music]
up down uh right left up down right left
I'm about to say that loud guys just
make sure I get it
oh they messed up already
Red's almost out of there
up down right left up down
it's good
okay I think we good with this
[Music]
okay here we go here we go up down right
left up down left down
up down right left up down left down
[Music]
man I gotta win this I gotta win the up
down left right up down left down left
right
up down left right up down left down
left right
there's no way they get through this I
should win here
[Music]
all right green come on a couple more
oh my God
up down left right up down left down
okay so it's it's vice versa okay
should be perfect we got this boys we
got this
[Music]
person
all right
[Music]
thank you
man that was hard
that was rough
[Music]
we good though
I just need two wins
I'm way ahead of people right now
okay so a
A's blue B's green
blue green blue
[Music]
I'm doing a little bit better on that
it's the controller though man
I used to be able to beat these people
on hard that's the crazy part
[Music]
okay we got red what's he picking
I hope this Atkins thing man
[Music]
I'm gonna try to stick to the ones in
the front
[Music]
they're the ones in the back
try to get this one real quick
[Music]
see I'm learning guys I've learned
need one more
[Music]
all right
jump run
[Music]
I
used to be really good at this game
[Music]
I don't realistically know how good I'm
at this game now
[Music]
I still got the decent reflexes for it
foreign
[Music]
in the Stream there
played a good amount of it man I really
enjoyed it I really enjoy Pokemon but
until next time peace